okay so now view page okay
now I will freely admit as soon as I own
as soon as I wrote this answer out I
wrote the first answer that came to mind
and about two thirds the way through I
was like oh there was a faster way so
I'm gonna tell you what the passed away
in a second but I'm gonna stick with
what I wrote let's think about I what
information you've got and what you're
asked okay you get the parabola it's a
standard as a parabola could get for
parametric's they tell you the equation
of PQ what kind of object is PQ starts
with the C it's a chord right if not it
may be a court of contact but I have no
external point that you know that's a
bad external point I've know a certain
point that would necessarily tell me
where that is so I don't need to say
it's a court of contact it's just a
chord and so they give you right there
tada
they gave me the formula and so they say
don't prove it which is fine
then they ask you to get this result in
part one now I just want you to look
really closely how many of you
immediately saw what to do as soon as
you saw part one you're like I know what
to do anyone what did you do Russell
okay so they give you you mean yep okay
so you've got Q and you've got PQ okay
now if you are not in the group of
people who saw it immediately what can
help you get there well they provide you
with an equation this one and it's only
got the parameter P and yeah and then
they ask you to prove an equation with
the parameter Q in it as well both of
them right so we're gonna have to get P
and Q talking to each other well because
you're knowing that this line goes
through Q you can substitute the
coordinates of Q over here into the
equation that's exactly what I did okay
it's not the only way I'll come to
another way in a second but it this is
this is how I think through what I know
and where I'm trying to go and therefore
what trajectory I take
this is what my solution ended up
looking at it's a it's a bit long
thankfully it's not hard algebra it's
just it's just lots of algebra but you
can see up the top I've stated what I'm
doing
I said PQ passes through so it's the
other yeah PQ passes through Q that's
right so therefore I can substitute the
coordinates of Q into that equation of
PQ I was originally provided so there is
y and there's X does that make sense
see I've just done a straight
substitution now this is promising
because I can see all good I've got P's
and Q's together as I was hoping but
I've got to do a fair bit of legwork to
get to this the first immediate thing I
noticed is that there are a s in what
I've written down and there are no A's
in what I'm supposed to end up with so I
look and I say oh look there's an A on
every single term so I've divided
through by a as a little side note the
reason I could do that is because a is
not 0 is a length you can't divide by 0
will you lose marks not writing that no
but it's true that's why we can do it so
I've divided through by 8 to go through
this line to this line from this line to
the next
what have I done I've just slightly
rearranged to make the factorization
easier how did I know they would have to
be some factorization what what clued me
into that fact its head again Russell
nice and clear
okay so remember I said I've said to you
guys many times when you have a result
to prove you've always got to keep one
eye on you're working and the other eye
on where you're supposed to end up you
look at this thing and it's incredibly
simple
for starters sound is a P squared there
P squared but I've got P cubed flowing
around so somewhere I'm going to have to
divide through by P I can't divide
everything through by P you've got this
term over here which doesn't have P in
it so I'm gonna have to do something
else that's how I knew some kind of
factorization would be required so that
kind of accounts for the middle few
lines in here once you get your
difference of squares there you pull out
Q minus P as a common factor and you can
divide through by that again for a
reason I've divided by Q minus P because
P and Q are equal think about that for a
second number one why aren't P and Q
equal think about it go back to the
original question why are PQ equal there
they're the gradients of two different
points of the parabola and if there's
one thing we know about prevalence on
four parameters every gradient is unique
every point on the on the parabola has a
unique gradient so therefore I could say
they're different and since Q and P
aren't the same that means Q minus P
can't be zero and that's why I could
divide through by that okay again are
you going to lose marks because you
didn't say that no but it's still
mathematically important what's your
there you just expanded and there's the
required result okay now Paul nicely
clearly could you describe to everyone
what did you do to bring P and Q to the
same equation because you did
differently to be weird that with the
same result obviously Ben what did you
it involved a gradient can you know it
yeah pull you paper that's fine nice and
loud
pause there you got the gradient from P
to Q so Paul has looked at this court
and he said I can find out this gradient
through what did you do because he's
bored on my way yep so so pours down
rise over run to get that gradient just
think about why that's a useful idea
because there are if you use these
coordinates P and Q in the same equation
to get that was what I was I was trying
to do as well okay that's not all though
you've got to go a little further what
did you do after that actually do you
want to tell us what you got for that
rise over run can you tell us what you
got P oh sorry P plus Q over 2 now
that's really really simple you can see
a whole bunch of stuff as kids hauled
out do you see how much is kids do that
for starters if their age why I think
there is look-look think when he does
this right think about what he's going
to get it here that's going to be a a Q
squared minus a P squared so there's a
z' up here then this is going to be 2 AQ
minus 2 AP and there's a s now it's
exactly the same thing we were doing
just in a slightly different context
okay probably easier to see because it's
a fraction so you're instinctively
cancelling okay you're also going to get
the same difference of squares that we
did down the bottom but it's a
diffraction so it's easier to see what
did you do with this once you had that
for okay so you found the gradient of
this slide here and we know that by
definition that is what's the okay so
you
this is hot on this is x squared or
equals 4a Y so you can work out the
derivative there just by making Y the
subject and it's x squared on to a isn't
it why can't we just say that the
gradients pain we're going to get P why
can't I just say that there's a single
word
proof you see that do you ever I told
you it like the you need to know the
reason why we choose the parameter to be
what it is it's cuz it's the gradient
okay
but if you get told to prove something
you can't just assume it that's that's
not proof means okay once you've got
that gradient there which of course is P
what did you do with it okay because P Q
is not just a chord right it's another
object starts with it in and look what
is it it's the normal yeah so therefore
you have another expression for the
gradient of this line namely it's minus
one over P isn't it right and from there
I'm pretty sure this statement you
required to prove it it falls out from
there as well
is that okay fix it did anyone do it a
different way again probably I've no
idea I think those are probably the
easiest ways to see it cuz it's all
about gradient and these two points
together okay so then we can finish off
so part two they say if the chords are
perpendicular show that P squared equals
two so this is all you had to do this is
all you had to do I found the gradient
of okay the gradient of OQ you could get
in the same way because they're both P
and Q are the same kind of point and if
there really are perpendicular then
their gradients multiplier to give
negative one like so right so I've
multiplied their gradients together here
P on 2 times Q on two gives you that
that gives you P Q it's value negative
four and you can pop that straight into
your result from part one to get the P
squared equals two that you need it okay